[Music]
today for our daily cancellation we turn
to the story of mma fighter and woman
beater alana mclaughlin now the most
important thing to know about mclaughlin
is that he is a male he's also former
army special forces
but mostly he's a male
and when i say he's a male i mean he has
xy chromosomes and a male reproductive
system and male gametes
so it makes a person a male he also has
a male bone structure muscle structure
he's male from head to toe from skin to
bone from his brain down to his cells
down to his dna
literally every part of him is male if
they dig up his remains a hundred years
from now no matter how much of him is
left they will be able to tell that he
was male
that will indeed be one of the only
things they will be able to tell about
him
that's because your maleness
or your femaleness
is one of the most ingrained most
permanent most enduring aspects of who
you are it's so enduring that it remains
even after you die mclaughlin will be a
male even when he doesn't exist anymore
that's how male he is think about that
if you're a man
even when you stop existing you'll still
be a man
and yet that didn't stop him from
fighting a woman in the mma ring during
the combat global prelims on friday
night mclaughlin fought and easily
defeated celine provost another mma
fighter to be more specific after
beating her across the head in the body
for a couple of rounds he eventually got
her into a submission hold and choked
her out
this was again a man beating the crap
out of a woman an event that in the past
would have been roundly condemned by
everybody when former ravens running
back ray rice punched his wife in an
elevator it was one of it was one of the
biggest sports scandals in nfl history
and rice was run out of the league never
to return
now we know that rice could have simply
come out the day out the day that the
security camera footage was leaked could
have come out and said um
said that he's a woman
asked everyone to call him regina rice
from now on
it's bad for rey to be to beat a woman
but regina
now
that's a different story
that's why alana mclaughlin is being
celebrated as a hero today after choking
a woman into submission but mclaughlin
is not the one i'm canceling today
yeah he's a cheater
a woman beater
a bad person for that reason
it's also a pathological narcissist
yes he's a he's a male who beat a woman
to a pulp and who identified fallon fox
as his hero fallon fox is the other
trans mma fighter who retired
a few years ago who twice fractured a
woman's skull and then bragged about it
so yes all of that is true and all of
that is worthy of cancellation to be
sure but as always
the bad guys disgust me somewhat less
than the cowards who knowingly go along
with the evil because they're too scared
and too selfish to speak out and the
announcers and commentators during this
farcical fight on friday night give us a
pretty good idea of what that cowardice
sounds like so let's go through some of
these clips first here is one of the
hosts before the fight
introducing alana mclaughlin and a very
very gingerly acknowledging that maybe
some people in the viewing audience
might have a problem with watching a man
kick and punch a woman for 10 minutes
listen
back here on compate global with rodolfo
roman my name is max bretos and alana
mclaughlin will be fighting here tonight
and the topic of trans athletes
competing
obviously splinters the conversation
quite frequently
however whatever side you think about
and whether you think that the trans
athlete should compete one thing we can
all agree on the sacrifices one has to
make to make that decision is bigger
than anything any of us would do on a
regular basis alana mclaughlin has had
to overcome
many hurdles in her life and her career
it's a journey that only her have taken
let's take a closer look at some of
those sacrifices that she has had to
make
as early as i knew there was a
difference between girls and boys i knew
that something was different
i grew up mostly in south carolina my
upbringing was
not exactly
standard it wasn't usual my parents go
to church five times a week wasn't the
best childhood we didn't have a lot of
money and of course growing up a queer
kid in the south it was never going to
be easy my family definitely was not
supportive and are not today
this family is not supportive well
that's good news at least
you like guy he says uh yeah my fam my
my upbringing was uh it was pretty rough
not usual my family went to church
that's all he has that's that's his only
that's his horror story of being raised
man
i had a pretty tough kid family went to
church
yep that was it
now i can tell you that i certainly
would not be supportive of my son
getting into the ring with women and
choking them on national television
that's not something that i would
support to put it mildly
and yet the announcer says that um we
can all agree
that the sacrifices made by a male who
beats up a woman are bigger than any of
the sacrifices that any of us have ever
made have ever made
we can all agree he says
and what he means of course is that we
must we must all agree
we are required to agree
just as his employers have told him that
he must agree
that's why his facial expression and his
stuttering stammering
delivery reminds you of a hostage tape
this guy knows how hopelessly screwed up
all of this is but he's cooperating with
the charade
and that brings us to the fight itself
speaking of the charade
fast forwarding a little bit to where
the foregone conclusion is realized and
the man beats the woman
let's listen to the announcers as they
very carefully wrestle with the
implications
of the spectacle that they themselves
are now a part of
big right hand i for one and are just
full transparency i don't know what to
expect i don't know how to feel about
this
but i pull for a lot of mclaughlin
because you've seen what you've gone
through to do go through what she has
done it's it's a seismic change in your
life but it's the pursuit of happiness
absolutely but you know at the end of
the day max it really does come down to
technique and skills you could be as
strong as you want
but skill technique
will always conquer well i agree with
you there rodolfo but that's a that's an
argument people will bring up and
they'll
they'll beg to differ
big now the strength trying to go trying
to go up does pretty well gets her on
the ground now as you can see our ground
game goes this is uh celine provost the
uh
uncharted waters yeah not your typical
wrestling double takedown as you can see
she had to hold her up there for a while
usually your the wrestler go straight
down for the knee area or even to the
ankles to be honest just to bring them
all the way down she had to lift her up
like a deadlift and then she brought her
down mclaughlin's got the back of
provost and now i have a really deep
tap
alana mclaughlin victorious in her mma
debut via the rear naked choke had to
take a lot of pressure to get there
but she did
yep beat the woman in the ribs
uh had her bleed in the face choked her
out
you know you hear them say
if you can't beat them join them well
if you want to beat them join them
in a lot of mclaughlin's case
now but the announcer says i don't know
how to feel about this but certainly
alana feels good and that's the most
important thing
i don't know how i feel or anybody feels
or how the woman getting pummeled in
submission right now feels but all that
matters is how the trans person feels if
it makes him feel feel good to beat a
woman who are we to judge the pursuit of
happiness
he says
this is the pursuit of happiness as this
this man is in the process of punching a
woman in the ribs
we all pursue happiness in our own ways
now i'm just paraphrasing the announcers
here a little bit and then finally um
here they are at the conclusion of the
fight
sharing their their closing thoughts
about everything that we've all
just watched
that was a game plan and it worked to
her advantage
kudos to celine she took the fight and
kudos to alana right now i'm sure a lot
of teenagers adults are emotional yes a
victory
for the trans community and
the conversations will go from here as
to
what's next for alana mclaughlin whether
this
should be part of the sport
right now that doesn't matter alana
mclaughlin has gone through hell in high
water to get here this was a fight that
was supposed to happen august the 6th
put on holds
finally here in the first week of
september second week of september it
happens
yes a lot of teenagers and adults are
emotional
does that mean by the way a lot of
teenagers and adults are emotional
watching this what
and but they're having conversations
and the trans community is having
conversations
and there are some who might say maybe
that this shouldn't be a part of the
sport that this sport should not be a
staging ground for men to beat the hell
out of women some might say that but
that doesn't matter now because again
the trans person feels good he's feeling
very good about all of this and that's
what matters that's the only thing that
matters in the whole world the world
itself indeed exists simply to make
trans people feel good about themselves
all of us on our death beds when
surrounded by our loved ones
we'll surely ask ourselves one question
did i during my life make trans people
feel good about themselves and woe to
those who cannot say yes on that day
what regret what terrible regret
again i'm slightly paraphrasing what we
just said now you have to ask yourself
do any of these men hosting this fight
and commenting on it actually think that
any of this is okay or logical or
morally justifiable
no
they don't
yeah i can read their minds and tell you
they don't
we can say with certainty they don't
yet they cooperate with this grotesque
absurdity and that's the story of our
culture isn't it
that's the story the story is not alana
mclaughlin the elana mclaughlins of the
world are not the ones driving the
radical social change that we're
witnessing
they're not the ones driving our society
over the cliff which is what which is
the the radical change we're witnessing
the change is as much the the same as
the change that a car undergoes when it
goes over a cliff and crashes on the
rocks below
civilization will not collapse because
of them
because of the ilana mclaughlins
instead the real revolutionaries
unintentionally
are all of the millions of normal
basically sane people
who know that what they're seeing is
wrong
who know that it is not okay
and they know why it is not okay
and yet they remain quiet
and then ultimately they're forced to
participate
in the evil that they oppose
but oppose silently in their hearts or
the opposition doesn't matter and
accomplishes nothing
you want to almost feel sorry for those
announcers who clearly want no part of
this
but are forced to take part in it anyway
but then you realize that they're not
forced
none of us are really forced
it's just that refusing to take part may
require sacrifice
and many of us are not willing to make
the sacrifice
no matter how great or small
all we have are excuses
we make our excuses
while our civilization rots away beneath
our feet
i'm personally tired of the excuses
i'm tired of gutless cowards like the
announcers in that mma match
who could have refused to to be a part
of it
or you know what's even better they
could have said sure yeah i'll announce
this match and then they could have
spent the entire time talking about what
an absolute travesty the entire thing
was
that would have taken guts
they would have lost their jobs
they would have lots of people coming
after them
but we're at a point now where you have
to do the thing that requires courage
and if you won't do it then you're no
better than
anyone on the other side
and that's why today ultimately
the announcers in that match and all
like them are cancelled
listen hit that subscribe button right
now do it right now i thank you for your
compliance it is
somewhat appreciated